in the last episode we trained a custom
model on vertex ai in this episode we'll
learn how to get batch and online
predictions from that train model i'm
nikita and this is prototype to
production where we go from notebook
code to a deployed model in the cloud
[Music]
we have a trained model
that we save to a cloud storage bucket
but ml is not just about training
what's the point of all this work if we
don't actually use the model to do
something right so just like with
training we could execute predictions
directly from our notebook by calling
model.predict
but when we want to get predictions for
lots of data or get low latency
predictions on the fly we're going to
need something a little more than a
notebook
just imagine if we wanted to process
large quantities of the flower images in
batches
a notebook probably isn't the best place
for this
or what if we wanted to use our model in
an application where users could upload
images of flowers and have them
identified immediately when you're ready
to use your model to solve a real world
problem with ml
you don't want to be manually executing
notebook cells to get a prediction
instead you can use the vertex ai
prediction service so let's see how to
use it to get both batch and online
predictions
step one is to get your model into the
vertex ai model registry which is a
repository where you can manage the life
cycle of your ml models from the models
section in the google cloud console we
select the import button
we give our model a name and then we'll
select a container
we'll use the pre-built tensorflow
container but if you're curious how to
create custom containers for predictions
check out the resources below
[Music]
then we need to specify the path to our
saved model artifacts and cloud storage
and then we can click import
this can also be done in the sdk and you
can find the relevant code snippets in
the codelab linked below
when the model has been imported we can
see it here in the model registry
you can see that the version id is one
but if we were to retrain our model we
could maintain multiple versions of the
same model there are two types of
prediction jobs we can run in vertex ai
batch
and online
batch prediction is an asynchronous
request it's a good fit when you don't
require an immediate response and you
want to process accumulated data in a
single request
on the other hand if you wanted to get
low latency predictions from your data
passed to your model on the fly
you would use online prediction
you can get batch predictions once
you've uploaded your model to the model
registry
but to get online predictions you'll
need to take an additional step and
deploy the model to an endpoint
this associates the safe model artifacts
with physical resources for low latency
serving to deploy the model i'll click
this icon on the right and select deploy
to endpoint
we give the endpoint a name
specify the compute and then we can
click deploy
note that there are some other features
i skipped over like auto scaling and
traffic splitting for when you want to
roll out new models but for simplicity
i'm using all the defaults for now
again all of this can be done with the
sdk so definitely check out the code lab
below if you prefer writing code to
using the ui
when the model is deployed we can hit it
like any other rest endpoint
this means we can call it from a cloud
function a chat bot a web app etc
for demonstration purposes we'll call
this endpoint from workbench
let's return to our workbench instance
and we can open up a new notebook
i'm also going to upload a flower image
to our instance so we can test our model
we'll import the vertex ai python sdk
and then we defined our endpoint
specifying the project number and the
endpoint id
you can find your endpoint id in the
endpoint section of the cloud console
and you can find your project number on
the home page of the console but note
that this is different from the project
id
when you send a request to the endpoint
the request is received by an http
server
the http server extracts the prediction
request from the http request content
body
the basic format for online prediction
is a list of data instances
these can be either plain lists of
values
or members of a json object depending on
how you configured your inputs and your
training application
the code below opens the image and
converts it into a numpy array
then we convert our numpy data to
typefloat32 and to a list
we do this conversion because numpy data
is not json serializable so we can't
send it in the body of our request
note that we don't need to do any
pre-processing here because we included
scaling and resizing the data as part of
our model using keras pre-processing
layers
if your use case does require
pre-processing the data check out the
resources on custom prediction routines
which are linked below
then we call predict
the result you get is the output of the
model which is a softmax layer with five
units
if we wanted to get a batch prediction
we can write this data to a json file
that we store in cloud storage and then
make a batch prediction call with the
sdk now i showed you the simplest way to
get a prediction for image data
but for more realistic examples you'll
probably want to send the image itself
directly to the endpoint instead of
loading it into numpy first
this will be a lot more efficient but it
does require a little extra work when
configuring your tensorflow model if
you'd like to see an example check out
the notebook link below and drop a note
in the comments if you want to learn
more or see a video on just that we
started with notebook code
and we now have a deployed model in the
cloud try this out for yourself by
checking out the codelab below and stay
tuned for the next episode where we'll
talk about some more advanced topics and
model training like hyper parameter
tuning and distributed training and
don't forget to like and subscribe for
more great content and i'll see you next
time
[Music]
you